reports blame NASA for creating chaos
with your star sign but there are two
good reasons for the change and neither
is NASA's fault it's a result of Earth's
orbit around the Sun which traces a
plane called the ecliptic the passes
through 13 constellations
over one year the Sun moves in between
Earth and each of the 13 different
constellations
the constellation that the Sun is in on
your birthday determines your star sign
but there's a catch
the ancient Babylonians wanted only 12
signs to match their 12-month calendar
so they left off the 13th sign the
constellation Ophiuchus adding it back
in causes some of the chaos
but the biggest change actually comes
from the earth itself
the earth wobbles on its axis taking
26,000 years to complete one rotation
which slowly changes which
constellations the Sun is in
and it's been 3,000 years since the
Babylonians
which means a big shift in the calendar
needs matching each sign
[Music]
for example if you were born on March
21st 3000 years ago you would have been
an Aries
but today you would be a Pisces
NASA pointed this out on tumblr and on
an educational page kids
but don't blame it for changing your
side
astrology isn't science so read
whichever horoscope you are
the stars won't mind